nicolas vidal bonjour bonjour à vous
heureux de vous retrouver ce matin dans
la matinale alors jean castex a été
testé positif au co vie de cette semaine
ça fait beaucoup réagir ça vous fait
réagir également ce matin et oui il
vient ce jeudi matin on va parler de la
belle boulette de la grosse cagade de
jean castex les test est positif ou kovy
19 ce lundi 22 novembre et le premier
ministre il en connaît un rayon sur le
sujet car il a déjà été qu'à contacter à
plusieurs reprises depuis le début de la
crise mais son charisme de gladiateurs
chers amis il avait préservé de
l'infection et nous l'avait gardée en
pleine forme jusqu'à 7 22 novembre 2000
21 mai alors que jean le premier depuis
de longs mois était pré emballés sous
vide tous les français pour faire
respecter les gestes barrières et bien
cette fois ci c'est à son tour d'être
isolé à matignon jusqu'à feindre
sanitaire il ya quatre pas dans son
bureau pour qu'il récupère et les
doliprane qu'on lui glisse sous la porte
d'ailleurs on a tellement mangé des
gestes barrière depuis deux ans qu'ils
ne tarderont pas à devenir une
discipline olympique pour paris 2024
vous verrez mais revenons rageant car il
est comme ça jean guilaine partagé
depuis lundi c'est une grosse palanquée
de personnalités qui ont dû subir le
supplice du coton tige après avoir fait
partie finalement de la délégation de
gens du doliprane
rien qu'au gouvernement on a dû tester
gabrias natale richard ferrand gérald
darmanin jean yves le drian qu'est
emmanuel macron on trouve aussi dans la
liste christine lagarde président de la
bce le président du medef parti martin
ou encore le gouverneur de la banque de
france françois villeroy de galhau car
jean castex même dans son infinie
charité infectieuses ont fait profiter
tout le monde n'est le plus embêtant
pour jean castex c'est la bamboche à
laquelle il a participé au ministère de
l'intérieur la semaine dernière avec des
élus de hauts de france à l'occasion du
congrès des maires qui ad'ailleurs fait
l'objet d'un joli cluster alors vas-y
que je te sert la louche que je tapote
l'épaule que je te laisse le museau et
que je te passe tu y en avait 1 cm mais
le cas contactez gabriela tas s'est
empressé de défendre le premier ministre
en disant pour l'été finalement humain
enfin oui on est humain mais la
différence que si en france et le rwanda
à 8 fait preuve d'humanité dans cette
crise sanitaire ces 135 euros olivier et
on a même vu clément bonne cacher une
photo parce qu'ils avaient masques à
côté de de jean castex s'est pas passée
inaperçue non plus en tout cas cette
contamination aux copies du premier
ministre selon vous bien sûr tombe très
mal
bah oui car même si la cavalerie
dépenaillé gouvernement tente de la
minimiser cette contamination met en
lumière la question du non respect des
consignes sanitaires par certains
membres du gouvernement et certains élus
elle démolit aussi la théorie officielle
qui voulait que le vaccin protège
entièrement de l'infection et de la
transmission aux kobe 19 d'ailleurs jean
castex assure lui-même le 20 et 21
juillet dernier chez nos confrères de
tf1 qu'une personne doublement vacciner
ne pouvait plus attraper le coc u19 tu
parles janot en réalité cette
contamination est lourde de sens car
elle contredit la parole même du premier
ministre qui nous assurer du contraire
dont il est lui-même lui-même la preuve
vivante cela renforce l'idée que le
comité des épiciers virologues du
gouvernement navigue à vue et tente par
tous les moyens de durcir les mesures
sanitaires à l' encontre des non
vaccinés avec des convictions aussi
fiable que celle de jean castex en
réalité personne ne maîtrise absolument
rien dans cette crise sanitaire qui
atteint des niveaux d'exagération
liberticide qui laisse songeur mais le
pouvoir politique à cette incroyable
capacité de résilience à évacuer tous
les sujets qui fâchent dans cette crise
terrible où le dixième magali petite
bise au passage à clément bonne qui a
supprimé 11 mans / et à gram une photo
de 800 masque avec jean castex est selon
vous le gouvernement est dans une
situation difficile à quelques mois de
la présidentielle
ben oui ce ouvernement ce mythe tout
sauf une impasse politique à cette
situation de plus en plus intenable il a
fait preuve d'une violence inouïe de
coercition contre 6 millions de français
qui ont choisi de ne pas se faire
vacciner alors imposant pas sanitaires
et des restrictions de liberté je ne
parle même pas d'eric dupond-moretti qui
a traité récemment ces français d'
irresponsable et de failles dans notre
système car nous vivons dans un pays
merveilleux où la discrimination est
totalement assumée par le pouvoir et
lorsqu'on veut faire le bien des
citoyens utilisant la force ce n'est
jamais bon signe alors depuis quelques
jours on nous bombarde avec une
cinquième vague à grands coups d'un
fonctions et de cette forte hausse des
contaminations qui pourrait voir de
nouvelles restrictions contre les non
vaccinés dès aujourd'hui pourtant le
fameux connu comité des épiciers
virologues nous a assuré la main sur le
coeur que le pass and i ter était une
partie de la solution en réalité en
réalité il n'a aucune efficacité et si
on ajoute à cela que la vaccination ne
protège ni de l'infection dit de la
transmission que reste t-il de valade
cette politique sanitaire totalement
ubuesque mais tant qu'on parle matin
midi et soir sept lits sanitaires tous
les autres sujets importants ils passent
à la trappe et la meilleure façon de
détourner les français du bilan
catastrophique des manuels macron cédant
septième vague d'entretenir la peur de
diviser les français de désigner non
vaccinés comme des boucs émissaires et
d'évacuer les naufrages diplomatique la
vente à la découpe de la france le chaos
social les problèmes graves d'ultra
violence et d'insécurité et de la
pauvreté grandissant dans ce pays alors
les pour finir les sens michel audiard
nous éclairer ce matin je cite les
conneries c'est comme les impôts on
finit toujours par les payer
merci beaucoup c'est la phrase du jour
là nicolas vidal la vente à la découpe
de la france on en parlait justement
merci c'était l'édito de nicolas vidal
ce matin